hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and author of McCain the
myth of a maverick I'm here in beautiful
downtown st. Paul Minnesota site of the
2008 Republican National Convention
which is much different context than the
2004 convention seasons back then both
before the Democrats in Boston and
especially the Republicans in New York
City near 3 the three-year anniversary
mark of September 11th the
pre-convention story in both places was
all about terrorism not necessarily just
policies in the war on terror but
physical of fear and threats of a
possible attack on the conventioneers
themselves Americans have grown weary of
the same war that the Republicans were
running on in the 2004 convention what's
at stake this year is very interesting
from the perspective of John McCain he
is a politician who for the last 10 to
12 years has been the epitome of a neo
conservative when it comes to foreign
policy he elucidated the doctrine of
rogue state rollback three years before
it ever occurred to george w bush to
advocate pre-emptive war however mccain
won his nomination this year based not
necessarily on hawkish Republicans but
on independents and Democrats in all of
the early state primaries that he won he
never even won a plurality among
Republicans he won a vast majority even
over Ron Paul of people who describe
themselves as independence Democrats and
anti-war so McCain's fundamental
challenge throughout this campaign is to
keep appealing to those independents and
Democrats peel them away from Barack
Obama in a terrible year for Republicans
while maintaining his hawkish
credentials among the Republican base
and you'll see him give mixed messages
depending on which the audience is he's
an eisenhower republican to democrats
and he's going to look in the eyes of
vladimir putin and see KGB when it comes
to the republicans so the great question
before this convention as it starts
today here in st. Paul is which McCain
are we going to see